u.s./china relations.
The world will be watching in
the hours and days ahead.
Let's get straight to CNN's Oren
Liebermann at the Pentagon.
Oren, what more are you
learning?
I understand you were listening
to officials explain how all of
this went down.
What can you tell us?
>> It started on Wednesday when
president Joe Biden gave the
authorization to shoot down the
Chinese balloo
N as soon as
possible.
There were tankers and others to
shoot this down.
It was an f-22 that fired an a 9
side winder.
The aircraft itself was shooting
itself.
The balloon between 60 and
65,000 feet so at incredibly
high altitude.
The one shot took the balloon
down and crashed into waters
below.
We saw some of the videos coming
out from eye witnesses.
This was an operation which we
saw building up to it.
As well as the ground stop on
airports along the post there.
Working in coordination with the
FAA and be other agencies to
make this happen.
The culmination of the Chinese
balloon that was a spy balloon
that tracked across the country
until it was shot down.
Worth noting according to a
senior defense official, they
effectively mitigated the
ability of the balloon to gather
Intel.
Crucially, that same official
said the U.S. Was able to do the
reverse, to gather Intel about
the balloon itself, the
technologies it has,
surveillance capabilities, what
Intel it can pick up as it made
its way across the U.S.
The U.S. Was gathering Intel on
the balloon itself.
They couldn't go into all that
much more detail.
>> Oren, one of the big
questions at this hour is can
they scoop it up out of the
water and learn more about this
balloon by retrieving it?
What more do we know about the
recovery efforts that are
underway right now?
>> Absolutely.
As you pointed out, those
efforts are already underway.
Navy and coast guard assets were
standing by already knowing that
this was the outcome the
military was going for.
The pay load, the object hanging
below that balloon about three
school buses long we have
reported crashed in about 47
feet of water the senior defense
official said.
Pretty shallow making it fairly
easy to recover.
In terms of what shape it's in,
what did the impact with the
water do to it, that's a
question we're waiting to find
out.
That will go a long way into
determining what we can do to
find out.
In terms of what more Intel can
be gathered about the Chinese
technology on board of this.
Also worth noting the officials
we spoke with pointed out the
explanation, the weather balloon
and flatly rejecting it saying
it had no credibility.
>> Oren Liebermann, thank you
very much.
Let's get straight to the white
house.
CNN's arlitt Saenz.
We heard from the president a
short while ago.
He was very emphatic that he
ordered this balloon to be shot
down.
What more can you tell us?
>> Reporter: He was, Jim.
President Biden was on air force
one traveling from Syracuse, new
York, to Hagerstown, Maryland,
when the military undertook this
operation.
President Biden spoke to
reporters just in the last hour
where he tried to clearly lay
out the time line of when he
gave that order saying he told
his military officials he wanted
to shoot down that plane as soon
as possible.
Take a listen to what the
president had to say.
>> On Wednesday when I was
briefed on the balloon I ordered
the Pentagon to shoot it down on
Wednesday as soon as possible.
They decided without doing
damage to anyone on the
ground -- they decided the best
time to do that was when it got
over water within a 12-mile
limit.
They successfully took it down
and I want to compliment our
aviators that did it.
We'll have more to report on
this a little later.
Thank you.
>> Mr. President, what do you
say about --
>> What's your message to China?
>> You're saying your
recommendation was from --
>> I told them to shoot it down.
>> On Wednesday?
>> On Wednesday.
>> But the recommendation --
>> They said to me let's wait
until the safest place to do it.
>> So the president quite
emphatic there that he did give
that order on Wednesday.
Of course, he had been facing a
slew of criticism from
Republicans up on capitol hill
who had slammed the president
for not taking action sooner.
We've heard from Republicans
today praising the decision to
shoot down that balloon but they
did say they wished he had taken
these steps much sooner.
There have also been Democrats
who have major questions for the
white house about how exactly
this has all played out.
Senator mark Warner, the head of
the senate intelligence
committee, said China itself
wouldn't have allowed a balloon
like this to fly over the
heartland.
John tester wants to hold
hearings related to this matter.
Certainly, the president's faced
a lot of political pressure.
He was asked what kind of
message this sends to China.
He did not answer that.
This serves as a major tension
point in that relationship with
China.
>> I think the United States has
sent that message.
Arlitt Saenz with me on the
phone.
With me is Jim sciutto.
Jim, to that point.
I mean, I guess we're reaching a
new I guess moment in the
relationship, tense relationship
between the United States and
China and president Biden making
it very clear on Wednesday he
wanted to shoot this thing down.
>> It's a critical moment, Jim,
in the relationship between two
super powers, which was already
tense and is now more tense.
Of course, the first hostile
act, China floating this highly
capable surveillance balloon
over the continental U.S.
Including overflying several
sensitive installations and now
a U.S. President making a
decision to fire weapons, fire a
missile from an f-22 fighter jet
to destroy that surveillance
balloon, but also critically
take it down in U.S. Territorial
waters off the coast of south
Carolina with ships on the
surface there, as we're told,
going to make an attempt, at
least, to collect what it can
from here that they can further
learn exactly what Chinese
capabilities are.
I think it's also critical to
note, Jim, as Oren was saying,
that the U.S. Was able to block
the surveillance balloon's
ability to gather intelligence
while at the same time turning
the tables to gather
intelligence on that balloon's
capability.
That's critical.
Big picture, this is a tense
moment.
It was already tense.
We had a U.S. Air force general
within the last week or so
warning his forces under his
command to be prepared for the
prospect of war with China in
the year 2025.
That's not the consensus
assessment from the U.S., but
it's not far off from the
urgency that U.S. Officials feel
about the prospect for
escalation with China in the
coming years, and now you have a
tangible instance of that with
missiles fired in anger or in
response to a Chinese
provocation.
It's a tense time.
>> Absolutely.
We might see more provocations
to come.
Jim sciutto, thanks for the
expertise as always.
We appreciate it.
>>> I want to go to CNN's Tom
foreman on the spy balloon.
Watching this all day, Tom.
Very dramatic conclusion to what
has been a tense few days over
the United States with this
balloon making it across the
country.
>> We're actually coming up on
three full days.
It's believed it took off from
China, came up over the aleutian
islands, Canada, then ended up
down in here.
That would be roughly an 8500
mile trip or 1/3 of the distance
around the world.
Let's look at what it came over
on the way here.
When we had these spottings
here, it gave us an idea of the
path it was following through
the United States here.
These reports maybe it was
guided to some degree, but this
matches up pretty well with what
the jet stream would do with any
balloon out there.
What did it pass over?
Close to a dozen nuclear
facilities, missile facilities.
Five or six large military
facilities on the way and some
fairly big towns.
It got reasonably close to
Kansas City, St. Louis,
Nashville and others before
coming into its finish at the
end.
Oren said something a moment
ago.
This is in 47 feet of water.
We had already looked at the
ocean shelf out here.
Up to about 35 miles before you
go out it can go up to 600, 700
feet.
If it's in 47 feet, that is a
very precise, excellent depth
for them to recover it in.
The it also means they know
precisely where it came down,
that it didn't get lost in the
fall and they know where it is.
Really important.
The question now is what are
they going to find?
One of the questions that
military analysts will have
about this is was the
information that was being
collected, the stuff they
couldn't block or whatever they
were trying to block, was that
native to this hardware?
Did it live here in some fashion
on some kind of drive, some kind
of chip, some sort of something
or was it being streamed to
China and is all the memory here
empty?
Does it mean it's useless?
Evenly if you don't have that,
you at least have the hardware
to give you an idea what it was
supposed to do, some of what it
might have been looking at.
Those are key things they have
to look at when they look at
this technology once they're
able to fish it out of the
water, which they hope they can